c'est un rejet complet de la politique
du gouvernement c'est ce que j'ai passé
mon temps à entendre en faisant du porte
à porte c'est euh je ne voterai plus
jamais PS et cetera bon donc c'est un
constat d'échec d'une politique d'un
gouvernement qui depuis qu'il est élu
voit 1000 personnes par jour devenir
chômeur en fait il est là le constat les
les les gens ne ne se compliquent pas
non plus la vie dans dans l'analyse et
ils ont raison c'est euh le chômage
augmente la précarité augmente 8
millions de personnes sous le seuil de
pauvreté he jeune sur 5 en c'est c'est
inadmissible dans notre pays aujourd'hui
et pourtant c'est vrai c'est la réalité
donc ce ce ce rejet face à des méthodes
éculées qui ne servent à rien en tout
cas qui n'ont aucun effet parce que ce
sont les mêmes recettes d'il y a 30 ans
bah oui c'est c'est une politique qui
est rejetée c'est c'est c'est c'est
logique le gouvernement s'y attendait
bon donc c'est qu'ils sont conscients
quand même qu' que ce qu'ils font ne
marche pas mais ce ce constat amène un
vote à droite voire à l'extrême droite
pas du tout à gauche ni àextrême gauche
non alors je me considérais pas en nous
nouvelle donne même avec des les listes
où nous avons construit un vrai projet
départemental avec d'autres partis
politiques avec des citoyens engagés à
gauche dans différents cantons du
Calvados et de la Manche je ne me
considère pas à l'extrême gauche je
pense qu'il faut bien comprendre ça nous
sommes à gauche alors que le
gouvernement n'y est plus c'est c'est
tout simple c'est dire que si déjà on
reprend toutes les tous les engagements
de François Hollande euh nous serions
très heureux hein notre ennemi nous
c'est vraiment la finance donc s'il
avait gardé ce slogan au lieu de le
mettre aux enchè je pense que nous
aurions été très heureux et je me
considérais encore aujourd'hui moi
Isabelle Attar député comme étant dans
la majorité donc en fait nous avons fait
de très beaux scores nous formons
aujourd'hui la 4e composante de notre
pays cette union de la vraie gauche
écologique ou de la Nouvelle Gauche
écologique comme vous voulez l'appeler
euh a fait des score entre 12 et 17 % à
la fois sur notre département du
Calvados mais également dans toute la
France donc nous nous c'était notre
première échéance électorale c'est notre
première candidature à des élections
sous cette forme là avec un projet ce
n'est pas une association de logo ce
n'est pas une association de parti pour
faire jolie sur la vitrine ou sur une
affiche c'est un projet un autre projet
de société pour la France qui est porté
par ces citoyens engagés entendu et
comment vous expliquez le le votre front
national puisque je parlais l'extrême
droit tout à l'heure qui qui voilà un
vote Front National
qui dépasse les 30 35 % dans des régions
où il n'y a pas un seul immigré soyons
clair c'est un vote de de contestation
maximum un ralbol on va jeter on va
mettre un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière et puis on verra bien ce qui
se passe nous n'avons pas pu nous nous
faire entendre suffisamment comme étant
une autre alternative au coup de pied
donc si vous voulez vraiment faire
avancer notre pays et combattre cette
précarité qui nous qui qui qui qui nous
fusille soyons clair cette
financiarisation qui est en train de
s'infiltrer partout partout que ça soit
dans la recherche dans
l'éducation dans les entreprises dans la
fonction publique bon soit on arrête
aujourd'hui et on reprend la main sur la
finance et on redonne le pouvoir et on
partage ce pouvoir dans la gaieté et
dans le réenchantement de la politique
soit on le laisse aux mains des autres
et les autres en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui c'est le Front National et
l'UMP